[Music]
[Music]
haha for once I didn't have to adjust
the mic as we started because I actually
did that for once happy Friday everyone
I'm Eric that's John Luke obviously
we're gonna be checking out Dishonored
yeah you know right latest kind of
standalone game dishonored death of the
outsider is standalone that features
Billy lurk and we're gonna get into that
right now
and so I saw you kind of pretty positive
about your experience so far yeah and
you played you know obviously dishonored
and sorry too right
so yep give me your kind of yeah I got a
got a real fondness for this 200 series
and not all the way through so we'll see
but so far I'm pretty happy with the way
the game plays like I like the powers
Billy has something like that thanks
let's get to the game cool so you're
gonna do a less spoilery section right
yeah so I don't worry about too much of
that
fun fact they've included all of the
updates that they added to Dishonored 2
so from the get-go you have a mission
access
I didn't mess with this into Saunders
one but they had a custom difficulty
slider sorry this r2 they added this
like later in the game but at that point
it already kind of been excited okay you
can get real crazy with this you can set
like your save to like one slot only or
like Ironman mode you can do you can
like remove the slowdown time on the
access wheel you can change enemy
perception lean visibility your footstep
noises like you can get real crazy crazy
with it that's super cool
more games should do this I might do a
video on this yeah just like that's
pretty cool like to be able to just be
like it's because it's like okay you
played the game like the way that they
designed it right right but then you
also then get to play the game in this
like very customizable way that you're
like whatever first cause it was just
yeah what's up under my arm ball go away
hello any key tenant
are you guys was half expecting to see
some trout let's hope it's not some kind
of omen
Billy Mark don't know anything about God
like figure why are you wait and then do
you want from me throughout the games
he's the one who gives all kind of our
mics in the game I headed up because I
thought we're gonna play that other
thing so yeah I've tried to adjust that
if it's still doing that goof tom is
here that's daddy's character from like
your mentor mentor yeah he was the
assassin who killed him for us and
dishonored one it's very good
here we go Islands beautiful yeah this
is great it's a great looking game i
don't know like comparatively it's r2 is
great yeah he seems like it's running on
very similar we are playing on a PC
right now Xavier great yes we are
playing on a PC I got the field of view
bumped up nice
what's up mister Achilles always
necessary playing on PC here alright
little trolley type thing yep so we're
gonna go to this upper district okay so
are there like objectives outside of the
missions that you can kind of do or like
okay so a new thing they've had in this
one is contracts which is you go to the
black markets which was in two or you
can get upgrades and you can you get
these alternate contracts so it'll just
get your extra money and they're these
like kind of bonus challenges you can do
which is very thief like that's cool
pretty cool kind of making the game more
like there's like some story breaks and
stuff right yeah so I like when I was
one more when I get stuck or I just
wanted to move on I'd kind of like swap
and go to a different
okay so here's all my powers right here
yeah I was just gonna ask actually yeah
so she has like a little like gun on her
arm and I have my standard lethal one
I've a non-leaf Electrical burst hey
this uh shoot like a little ball it
doesn't seem like it'll hit anybody I'm
trying to figure out what it's for yet
um maybe distractions I got a hook mine
then I got my three powers so in the
game you only have the three as opposed
to in Dishonored to where you get like a
ton of them but I find them all
incredibly useful so the first one here
will do is displace which is like your
your blink okay very like traversal
traversal you make a impression of
yourself and the cool thing about it is
that you can leave it so I could oh so
you could back travel if you wanted to
we can essentially use it as like a get
out like okay I'm gonna go fight these
dudes no thing here Sam like in trouble
or something
I can just quickly go like that sound
brake crazy no no no no you can't that
hard but you can use it to get yourself
out of a situation which is the second
thing is foresight which was there yeah
this is way cooler than that because
what you do is you actually project
yourself and then you can move around
and you tag stuff okay that's a building
I need again two bath salts I can tag
this worker
over here this guy so you can talk all
these people and now I can see them just
so and it will kind of see another
situation essentially lets me get an
idea what like your layouts gonna be and
you can kind of plan like routes and
when you do it also shows you like
guards patterns so you can see like
where they're gonna walk and stuff like
that it's okay really really that's how
you tweet earlier today like that you
and though there's less powers and I
feel like it's a more focused experience
because of these powers so yeah
definitely whoa
oh no yeah good old tomorrow
hello DK and no villa alright welcome
yes right Paul Porter is her story it
definitely feels like a more focused
focused experience in a really good way
rather than have like a ton of different
powers I had these three powers some
ones which we'll get into in a sec that
all are very distinct have very specific
purposes and I can use them to do
chilling accomplished yeah what you need
to write yeah so what's up Jeremias
thank you for tuning in appreciate it
from just just doing it just doing her
job
sweep it so I'm just talking around
three I'm not gonna kill her
so I have to get inside this exclusive
club SiC sweet couldn't just use
something like a Sharpie join occult man
you gotta go away man don't flinch she
didn't even have like a shot of liquor
or anything before she did that Richard
asked as her arm do anything sir well
one arm has a gun on it right and then
what about her like crazy arms now crazy
arm it doesn't do anything
babari you just stabbed people with it I
you get this cool like sword that wow
I'm not sure what it does yet but okay
cuz I just got it but at least visually
it looks really rad seems like her arms
more for visual flair at the moment
that's fair okay so basically I find out
shot two people who are part of the
skulls that I need to go at - yeah well
the other cool thing about this is they
actually removed the the chaos system
okay which kind of like essentially
graded you on like how and that would
actually like affect the ending of the
game that yeah I remember that people
were kind of salty about that nothing
like really knowing they got rid of that
you can still choose whether to kill or
not kill they still have when you beat a
level like though but score you on if
you want to be
stealth or not so for those kind of
players you want to have like that
really hardcore experience I can do that
but the game doesn't seem to affect you
or punish you that's good
mocking 27 he did showcase two of her
abilities already one was kind of like
the traversal blinky yes I can kind of
put a projection of herself and then as
long as she's within line of sight
returned to that projection the other
one was kind of like he described John
Luke described it as kind of going
ethereal and then being able to scout
around the map detective vision ish
esque I guess a little bit I don't know
he showed his okay a gaming slash heart
asking what's your favorite weapon to
use in game the game I played the game
pretty non needful for those guys so
your spell's games I playing himself the
trip mines are pretty cool
sweet right so I want to get it I'm
gonna get over here where that's the
black market yeah always be saving Matt
Marcel asking what is your favorite
arm-based weapon of all time
question now maybe the rocket punch from
a fan pain good like oh I remember that
yeah you can control it right yeah just
reminds me around and like of like some
mecha
[ __ ] you know like some like yells like
rocket punch really something stupid
like really showed us that were like
holy crap so yeah man I'm controlling it
it goes like kind of slow super stupid
that was a good one actually I totally
forgot about that is there a different
trick to this blink ability it's
basically like he has to put a
projection of himself right yeah so the
difference is I can act I can set it
down and then activate it later
yeah this is kind of what makes like a
nice like a retreat type of thing you
know you're gonna go in and possibly get
in trouble or something
so you're the contracts I got there's
kidnapped the bartender killed this mind
workplace irassman and see this missing
brother these are all really tough okay
I struggled with some of these
especially what's the what's our best
bet here probably the missing brother
that's the easiest one to do I find okay
let's do that one the bartender one's
tough cuz you have to like kidnap this
bartender and I'm like I know how I'm
supposed to kidnap this guy cuz he's
just constantly surrounded by people at
the bar
can't you just kill them all you could
there's a lot of people can't you kill
them I'm a my mind so the mine one's
tough because you can kill the mine but
that's you have to make it look like he
commits suicide
and you he has like people around him
yeah so I know where to get him to
commit suicide or to look like him in
suicide it's trying get him there is
quite okay you guys let John Luke out of
the dungeon good to see him back hey man
he's been making history of okay these
guys played he's got one coming up soon
history of a 2d metroids right yep
that this weekend yep plan for a plan
for this weekend so uh black market it's
like in like well looks like there's a
way to break in I haven't figured out
how to break it in this one yet always
fun to get in there and yeah take what
you want
that's something with these games I just
like exploring there's a lot you can do
oh I can show off a pretty cool thing so
it's it's pretty rad and it's not
actually a contract or a main mission it
was just kind of a cool thing to happen
I guess it kind of is spoiling though
mocking 2010 but they wanted to know how
many missions are there in total I do
not know okay but the game I'm on the
fourth mission and I'm about four hours
in okay so like it could be about an
hour ish permission yes and uh Harvey
when I talked to Harvey Smith at
QuakeCon he was saying that some people
have taken as long as 12 some people
taking the ground like a dish so around
like around 9:00 Tennessee it probably
depends - like how many contracts you do
things like that right how much
sidestepped exactly
gube saying the can't wait because the
history of bids have been amazing so far
in a job at John Luke okay we're going
around scanning with the all-seeing eye
evil as possible so I kind of get a so
now I can see all these people just
really very nice
I'm gonna try and get behind this guy
[Music]
yeah hot reload classic I was just
honored experience I would just like on
boil kill something in I was really
trying to this ability on him though 27
bring up a good point saying that
they're liking this trend of the more of
the six to ten hour bigger kind of like
either DLC or standalone for like
chapters yeah like kind of for thirty
bucks like old blood lost legacy yeah no
totally old hunters was like really good
old hunters was a good alone yeah but
I'm just talking in terms of like a
meteor DLC yes but it was like it was
pretty much like having to do season one
I guess is kind of doesn't count up to
this DS like you know it looks like a
guy that's for sure John I hit the wrong
button
oh well [ __ ] it up he's a rock man now
does it actually rip his face off does
it rip his face off just borrow
what's this Leatherface Texas Chainsaw
Massacre there you go
serious we guy's face yep and now oh is
this the new iPhone where it has facial
recognition scan sorry so now I just
look like that guard what I just walk by
now yes see you make direct eye contact
with them they will start to notice
something's up so you got to be careful
about it
are you serious though alright seems
possible I guess now it's um there's
some limitation for it you can only do
it to a person once which is why I had
to find another guy okay bar up here it
will not go down as long as I'm not
moving but when I'm moving it starts to
go down so you have okay so it's not
like it's like crazy ope
yeah but very and like I said if there's
a lot of people and they see you you
know yeah can you just look down the
whole time hey Marcel if it's a good six
to ten hour standalone DLC or standalone
you know game I'll take that over
something like Mass Effect Andromeda for
60 bucks
right
yeah I mean I've always kind of been an
advocate for shorter experiences that
are like yeah like fun for ow as opposed
to like I think like this game must be
this many hours long and whatever yes
about the experience I think it was
hilarious you weren't there during the
lobby I think this is when it happened
this week during the lobby my brains
kind of all scrambled but it was kind of
funny because Mike made the joke you
know is at Mass Effect Andromeda expense
and I think it was Callie or Rob that it
was like nope dude so it's already dead
like leave it alone yeah I feel about it
nothing like a nice little evening but
ya know it's had its had it to do yeah
mocking tone 7 hey did that mana bar
totally refill yeah so that's the other
thing you don't have to UM find vowels
anymore trap door stays closed that
seems
so this guy's trying to give a speech on
this thing has a trapdoor for players so
pull up here pack up some guards let's
try and find door all right here's the
lever okay where we need to be you get
down there now um
I don't need to kill him I just need the
coin what I did last time when I played
last night is so no I I snuck all the
way around it got through there and then
why he was turning around me and then
you just teleported could you see
yourself to to through that little
crevice what were you able to see
yourself through that tiny crevice to
like teleport out - would that be
possible
what do you mean so like you said
there's a little sliver right between
the curtains there that you oh I think
think of that like putting it there no I
just kind of like hopped away like
you're behind oppression and then stole
it oh that's kind of neat we could try
that I don't know if that's possible I
thought that's what you're talking I did
it to try it that's kind of cool
you know what let's give that a try and
if that doesn't work that will do the
the trapdoor to the trapdoor plane
sounds good sleeve
[Music]
giblets
you know jank well hello boys no real
awkward awkward that guy kind of it's
still working we're playing still hard
seven-leaf gaming asking so far do you
prefer dishonor to or death of the
outsider special abilities
I like abilities I like specifically how
I like my issue with the dishonored tune
and it's not like a bad thing it's just
any type of game those who this is when
it gives you too many abilities yeah you
tend to be like the ones my thing is
still there
that's a Louis right that's too far away
David that's why the site I'm damn sorry
jauntily that's a cool idea though like
i thought that i i i haven't played too
much dishonored personally i enjoy
watching it especially some of those
crazy runs that okay alright so we could
have tried putting the projection
possibly closer somewhere but yeah okay
but there you go i was able to get the
keys like half of that was there half of
my idea was there it was a good idea i'm
a little limited so the alternate plan
we're gonna do is we're going to hot
game of the year come on we had to at
least finish him there before we try to
get those i agree that jerk
but yeah if you guys are curious about
this game it is out today $30 right yes
actually get relative well I figured out
why I couldn't hit him cuz he has a
helmet on get him right in the neck
gently try something else
I'm an alternate plan alright well I
mean this is kind of the beauty of these
games is implementation right right I
mean even what I tried to conjure up
which is like you know a little kooky
but alright we're good okay that guy
that's that Lester kill him take this
key it's like the prestige and we're
gonna leave more people here
you haven't watched the prestige you
should it's a good movie I enjoyed it a
lot quite a bit I actually owned the DVD
all right there we go
sweet did it that was the that was one
of the one the dudes I to get sweet no
problem awesome I like it contract one
done oh I'm Jes was like huh no
quicksave there he quick saved right
before the anger he's like before we
were trying to step out so I think it
worked out alright what's up James
Thomas Matt Marcel saying dishonor to
was 11 11 to 16 thank you for the
specific date all perfect okay we can
get
how great was that movie yeah I know
right it is gonna be solid it's all it's
all right so we need to get his key
right here so our goal is we're trying
to get a knife okay I can kill the
outsider and poultice and I have the
night it's in a bank vault so apparently
this is in a bank vault and there are
two keys genuine has can you turn back
around
like just look above you right here oh
I'll go to the taxidermy shop that was
the other thing I wanted to show off
okay we would stuff like that an
interesting little tidbit here behind
oh so you can see through stuff too okay
so it turns out there was a secret thing
he has been doing these like crazy
experiments where he's been like
murdering people like like they've been
taking their blood and like draining it
from them to put it into themselves to
get closer to the void Wow it kills
people okay so that guy I just killed he
did that to somebody basically we got
evidence for it now and you can deliver
it to this newspaper God to like review
like you know he's crying
in this case I already killed them so
okay I can if I want but there's not
much reason but if you choose to not
kill them you can also you know get him
and schools says kind of more anxious
for the new you will within but I always
wanted to give it dishonor to try I mean
this could be do you feel like this is
the way to kind of get into it now that
it's out let's say someone hasn't played
this honor right we think that this is
the way to get into it or do you think
they're just better off playing
Dishonored 1 or just 1 or 2 first that's
a tough one so the game is certainly
standalone experience like you can play
this game narrative Lee it takes place
after two so there are certain it
doesn't really like it too much and do
it but there are certain story elements
that if you like really wanted to
experience the whole narrative fresh I
would recommend playing this one right
away there but if you don't care about
that if you're like oh I just want to
play this game and I don't really care
about having known the previous games
like so you'd say that if you were to
like let's say I made a comparison right
like I know cuz like when I asked I feel
like I asked you the same question
during Uncharted where else legacy and I
feel like at least with that one you
were more like Oh like you could totally
play this game it'll be like a really
good experience if you haven't played it
uncharted and it's totally fine sure
this one kind of the same but if you
want a better narrative experience
probably want to play I would say so um
they kind of set up like why the
outsider be someone you'd want to kill
but I think the context of the other two
games just kind of give it a little more
weight
let's see where next
ah kill the sound no quicksave see we're
back to sweet okay I was when you're
dead like that are you able to pan the
camera around I don't think so
I was just curious if you could actually
see if there was like some type of a
other thing laddering you could have
fell on right I guess you just have to
find out the hard way yeah let's try it
this way
nice hot murder some people Oh what was
that noise yeah this is what I'm talking
about John Bull lethal this game is
rough well we thought you trying to do
that
this is stand alone a battle pants one
death count two now goop don't worry
count to 1 by self-inflicted and the
other was because I told him to go
weapons hot
What's Up boo g7 welcome long time no
see
good to see you
nothing like that hi-yah what okay I
didn't see that window she's a lot she's
in it we're just kind of I like I was
like that about the games he's blank in
weird ways here we go taxidermy yeah
that's that my my need to kill so oh
here's a cool thing
okay you can talk to rats in this game
so they're saying if we read the mission
clue yeah they're basically saying they
can smell fresh meat in a nearby
basement zone may be in danger but there
are bloat flies near mine okay
trapped in cellar no way save me alright
we're those notes coming from though I
don't know I was trying to figure out -
I was stuck in a cellar but I'll find a
way to give these rats different maybe
one of the notes I found just great said
like I'm in the taxidermist alright you
gotta figure that out because it's
nearby yeah like ha rats that Walter's
this shop
welcome welcome feel free to look around
just looking around so yeah so here's a
there's that thing ah don't know what's
up with that maybe it's something to do
with the blood and stuff that's weird so
we got a basement we can't get in it
she's got the key okay so the way I did
this didn't need your help looking at
any of these possessions you have so
thanks for your keys on you John Luke
she was smart
but apparently it did not alarm her
get out of here while you still can
thank you thank you that awful woman
keeps all that blood amber locked up but
the key it's beside her work table take
it all okay how's daddy making lock him
in so he runs away there are these
blowflies here if I wanted I could open
it up and like like what this it'll kill
him oh if you had done that mattress or
yeah before I like yeah the other thing
yeah basically these um the both ways
are from - yeah I remember those nest
inside corpses it's to clean that up
burn that body alive all right so you're
still sticking out I like it
yeah level of gaming this is pretty cool
especially when you start getting like
really proficient with your skills and
like
Maps I would say like if you're
interested there's something really cool
you know like
like crazy good players that do like
crazy Road gamer something does these
insane runs where he will like bleh
he'll clearly play through a level like
20 30 times yeah he knows the exact
route and then he'll do this like fluid
run that's just awesome I love watching
this stuff he did a bunch for one and he
did some for two not as many as I wanted
for it to you like I was doing a man see
I'm hurting him that body by the way I
got me out like I'm foot fly amber worth
sweet all about that money all about
that money so which is clearly what
she's doing with these to sell them yeah
like harvesting them or like exact
putting them into people to then hard
key I can unlock sweet squad Amber's
money chicheng
what's up level of gaming and what's up
Tonya Cindy scene
story-wise how long after Dishonored 2
does this a place it definitely takes
place but as far as
deathclaw it could be one of those
things where it's like maybe they
thought there were spoilers you know
like it's tough like it is one of those
games
because it's so like it's only x-men
hours and we're showing off some of it
you don't want to see it hard to say I
think with these kind of game
after like build up a like following for
the following specifically for this kind
of game like you're here to watch me
played this game like in a crazy way
it's fair so yeah that was a love that I
more stuff like this please and then
here you go she's like why don't we just
do that to take her because at the time
we didn't know for sure okay why was she
staying there that's what I wondered
because when the guy runs out she's got
to be like Oh somebody's here or like
hey my gun
my secret trap gun went off hmm so
burning dead bodies case money sort of
it's only because they have the like
boat fly nest around which then when you
coagulate the two I guess you get a
blood hammer Jael is cold as ice yeah
sometimes let's see so we're gonna we
can mark these by the way so we can kind
of look at them we could try and do this
so maybe the promise they're just kind
of like in my are they and they're
always there they're always here so I
wonder if it doesn't matter as much if
they don't see me do anything weird if I
could just are you gonna like stun them
while you kill them or something you
could just like just save it I'm just
gonna knock them out nothing to see here
people
then you're pretty strong so what do you
have to do with them now so we're going
to look like he's dead right let's go
back long time sometimes they do gmf I
think it depends on the game but that is
this is a bag seven-leaf gaming saying
is actually possible but you said you
can glitch inside the mine with booing
can explode him yes you can that does
not get you the reward but you can do
that I did do that yesterday whoa are
you neo from the matrix again another
movie spoiler that's what I'm here for
okay chaos is God's go back so you not
have to worry about he's gone
so that was not the most efficient way
to do that but you probably can't take a
face and carry him like a guard right
that probably would work look um I once
I like a kind of spoiler count like two
man and there are very old movies well
not very old but they're old
this was actually out already it is out
today so you look questioning my own
sanity
came out today
see we can still make this work but I'm
nope oh did you not hold on to it it did
not work needs to go pee though don't
okay experiment number two Evan I have
an idea
keep we can make this work if iMovie
gets over the decade mark I think you
missed the bow I would still say
something just still worth watching I
just have to finish my [ __ ] finish that
guy where's your mind dude oh there is
then give me yo face
it's like face-off nope me carrying it
do not know another spoiler right in the
kisser
okay alternate plan we just knew caves
the whole time that's right no so let's
just murder down
you okay caster so he says keep alert
oh you and I hope it's available in
Turkey for us yeah [ __ ] that up
wash your face you're getting shook my
numb or something yeah pulling out the
tripmine activated semblance so it's
kind of like what was that noise
so when shooting us there's a river over
to our right that oh I don't know what
happened there that was weird it's
almost like it hooked you - yeah that
was cool that's that guy's just doing
his thing
thank you for all that current
references right now he's sorry innocent
bystander no witnesses he just didn't
turn around there's no witnesses here
for John Luke oh [ __ ] I better watch my
back guys John we've might have to whoa
did you just boom that's what you're
supposed to do yeah oh it's so like no
way it knows yes so let's contract
are you contracts let's find out it's
possible I could have negated it just by
being caught nope i negated it so I
think what happened was at some point I
just got caught with it so that's how
you would do it we're just gonna move on
alright yeah let's go back and melee
saying I didn't see a thing
man nothing did nothing nice case shut
[Music]
is everywhere kill em all
that guy in particular I just need a
little face okay so dark I need a face
oh man see I almost do it no I almost
want not movie reference and more TV but
then since it's a more current I won't
go there okay I don't know level of
gaming you might be in trouble when I
come after you what else well for us
today Houston Texans beat Cincinnati Bay
what's up Gavin Griffin
we get her just waltz it away like
nothing's happening happen her
hope come early is the PC version of
this game as bad as the Sun or - no it
is good it's fine
yeah no the PC version designed to had
some issues I don't think it was as bad
as people made it out to be to be honest
like it wasn't like it ruined the game
but it certainly wasn't issue that
needed to be fixed and they kind of
sucked you know where you're trying to
run the game in really high settings
yeah it's just giving you issues and a
piece of [ __ ] building right it's
definitely an issue those are just like
that's tough it's tough but this one
I've had no issues yet I hadn't like put
it through its paces you know but but I
mean like issues that we're having with
- like I had those issues as well those
are probably more apparent like sooner
alright are you gonna do that window
trick you did last time
get up here you dumb dumb guard you
can't as well pretty far away
I don't know horse package 9 Eric did
you get hard light no I have not I've
got I've literally gotten so many dupes
of exotics I don't want to talk about it
let's go back says that guy said face to
face take his face what you doing there
with that old gentleman and all right oh
ok so I know you got a crazy eye but I
didn't know you had crazy ears - I got
Chu yep kill her and a business
associate turning the snipe in so that's
the thing I'm I'm gonna kill them in a
way that doesn't attract
level of gaming the reason that Billy
lurks right Arvin's the way it is is
because the outsider essentially did
that to her
yeah a little spoiler for two so in in
one tube she just she's missing an arm
in and I there is some time travel stuff
that happens in two and you have the
ability to get her eye and arm fixed by
changing the time you don't have to do
it but you can so the game essentially
this game the way they get around that
is they treat it as like it's a time
paradox where in some reality it was
changed in other rallies it wasn't so
the way the outsider fixes it is by just
like taking her aya on the way and
giving her the magic version essentially
you like the logic she also isn't aware
of it so she was like freaking out
because she has dreams about her missing
an arm and I doesn't know what they mean
because the time stuff
Kovach says it's a magic eye with the
directional mic okay make sense to me so
I guess I just like pop up in his head
shot these noobs I don't wanna try that
yeah I think she's dead okay so we're
good
idiot who maybe maybe he thought what we
thought oh she's just taking a nap she's
dude that's so cool though
in fact uh-oh me likey okay hey guys a
drink
Let Me In The Spectre is a private club
are you a member
dude that was pretty awesome like how
she's just stuck on I like a big
knowledge like a crappy tattoo probably
wouldn't be a very good tattoo yeah cuz
you're doing it on yourself you're like
just that straight I imagine she doesn't
do much tattoos Pro gay or pro gamers I
think that's like short okay that was
cool I think it was like with the
execution Perry's
so there's this terminus say from there
I won't get there unfortunately can't
like use your ability to get in your
displace it was like myself in their
block
that's a bartender I need to kidnap not
kill just kidnap one thing it's like
basically rich people being like instead
of drinking alcohol they like that looks
like the two people he just kills hey he
said may I help you at least one gaming
company appreciates good grammar yeah
like what is this like what do you have
in the same blood type
rich blood super weird surprise guys
it's tomato juice so we can that's the
dude who's currently being cooked up
who's also the contracted brother we're
trying to find
so let's uh hey chop the door are you
feeling oh I'm good how are you and he's
got a lot of he's going full on that guy
this thing says hey don't reverse that
so just pull that little switch there
I'm guessing we're gonna steal that blow
so they were taking his blood for those
three rich people okay we're crossing to
the other side John Luke literally dying
there we go nice I like that as we came
out touch now the other thing is I don't
know how to get him out without alerting
everyone downstairs great I do not know
how you do that oh just my drunk brother
here he had a little too much to drink
you know the second you're walking with
him very they are all about you
but you have to get you're supposed to
get them out get rid of that evidence
and these huge blue trunks
so first off I need to get rid of these
guys really fast
oh how you guys doing not so great
anymore huh like man at the backstab
they're just full front full front
stabbed playing cards Oh kind of
bleeding around we wanted that hand of
cards I like that they got rid of the
chaos system because it really just
frees me up to experiment more
pigeon-holed or I feel like oh if I do
this it's my ruin I like my playthrough
unless you're going for like a pure so
much murder that's right it's what you
want that's what I want what you want to
see so we should try to get Alberto
Alberto
this door over here also leads to a the
house I need to get into it's an
alternate way in I can't take him with
me through there I was trying to see if
I could play maybe take him with two two
birds with one stone so did you only
played out in the main store Dishonored
one I did not know that is that like a
thing they patched in you could like
play it's like watching doom gube says
yeah man
doom is pretty hot stuff yeah I should
have tried okay what's up I don't know
how to get this is the part where I'm
always like you just go I can't like a
lot of people there's a fair amount of
people and they are all up on me the
second I go in that private door doesn't
work
so I don't know how to get them all how
can you steal a person's face and then
carry him out I tried that it wouldn't
work like I would get I get like here
and then it would bring sneakers one
time I got right up to the door and then
it's always broken for me can you smoke
all five of them I don't know it's like
how are you gonna get him out man just
run but yeah it's like maybe I should
kill them all you try kill them all
quick save all right who's got weapons
oh my god well you got to kill that oh
you got kidnapped that bartender so
maybe kill everyone but the bartender
[Music]
where'd you come from gentlemen
gentlemen Lee bodyguard you get really
overwhelmed and I'm not good enough to
like that's fine
all right so what do you let's see here
let's see we knew about doubt being in
DLC oh yeah but someone was saying a
main story for a while you just have to
switch some files on PCs what Bob so
this is just a reskin then at that point
or is it actually swapping the powers
around it's probably what ends yes it's
just like a reskin thing in so in in
this game when you beat it you actually
get to play you can choose to play the
game with Emily or corvo's powers okay
so you can kind of do the same thing
except it's now official we're just
gonna try booking it drunk and we need
to take him home see ya try to get your
asses up here you can't
okay oh hey look the marbles not there
no weird we know what happened to him
taken let's be on a break most feeling
like a 10-minute break or something see
someone's not feeling oh oh oh
hey come back here sir Yeah right done
relax sir
you guys just taking a nap cool we did
it nothing to see sweet all right what's
next so we shrunk in her house all right
let's see that that could be maybe the
ending the ending here the climax let's
see so I could go back through that
place but now they know I can go through
the front entrance but I need oh yeah I
just keep painting see he didn't he
wasn't a witness right John like that's
why the killer
so this woman you need I can't help you
she help she's a lover of the other
guy's house back here
oh is it is that the that's the texting
person think so so yeah like a secret
knock what they use way to leave that
out well because as you use dogs model
powers and gadgets we can do is we can I
haven't tried this before
may not work because I oh I just
semblance into a dude you should not
have witnessed a murderer let's take a
little damage when you do it worth
where's her head oh my gosh body parts
everywhere it is yeah you know a Bratz
somewhere we're hooking you love is the
leg didn't go as planned no it did not
yeah we can listen to rats to go back
yeah when we talk to rats I like that
that's cool they did give us insight
into that dastardly lady's plan get
people but harvest their bodies after
she's put the blowflies in them instead
we robbed her okay
make it progress nice I like it
show yourself no ain't nobody here just
your imagination playing tricks on you
it's hard to do what you need to do a
face SWAT ugly a face off do you know
the secret knock
it's two sets of three shoot come on we
did the secret knock Enoch oh no is the
maid she was just doing her job
oh no she had no chance
oh so the reason I got caught there is
because um dogs dogs can smell you
through this out and they the semblance
doesn't work on them and I was praying
that dog was sent back is family dog et
SD from the destiny just kidding wrong
the wrong room guys wrong room guys
what's actually a pleasure smart here
tag some pools we do some we do smart
things
he's definitely gonna come over here so
I got ready to go
I kind of already know how to do this
place that's why I got it before well
yeah out of mana so let's get to
he's too hot was in the month of ice
he's coming
they tow the room yeah face that's what
that doesn't make sense
she totally saw you dub well we said I
think I was able to get up quick enough
okay I need to get into this room this
right here okay
this is that the chest trash chute dumb
well that's the dumb one I don't know
Dumbledore it's the it's the elevator
that the servants go into they use it
for food and [ __ ] don't dumb we doorbell
don't wanna dumbbell waiter I'll figure
something dumbwaiter dumbwaiter it is
dumbwaiter Oh got it
I looked up servant elevator food
[Music]
door closes face is bad hearing so I'm a
waitress hello I belong here please
I thought you jumped me I thought you're
just following because we needed just
gonna go give the master some food
we're going up all the way up
I've never seen it but I'd heard enough
from Dowd to know it's not a place you
forget Oh some resin evil stuff or
something
hi something gotta be right or maybe
it's just it's just like there to trick
you into thinking yeah thing and they
spent like 15 minutes trying to like do
something and they tried that
oh what a convenient little opening Oh
like it pretty well yeah that was
excellent
that's what I sound like when I do a
rock band therefore I don't you rock
that or karaoke that guys supposed to be
professional oh yeah this is good for
the time okay so here's the same crap
Nicki essentially it's a musical lock
okay everywhere it's Papas autograph
audio graph
[Music]
kill him or not I know that's your car
hand like this very slow opera singer
though normally I'd have to pay a
fortune we don't want to hear any
singing anymore even if he is a
professional very useful you're playing
it on your own hard boat oh yeah I don't
really like playing these games without
a hug too
moving things like like a health is fine
but I like removing any sort of
indicators like that you don't like yeah
I I don't like some like that because
you want to try to discover it yourself
exactly and again these games are really
well designed where you can discover
yourself like you don't need to know
like where his private quarters is
because you'll find on the walls like
maps of the house and you can go okay so
over here in this and that so I don't
think I have the clue but it shows
there's a there's a clue that there's a
special room he has read keeps all his
collections on the second floor
but what if it was a young master who
knows Oh big action but that room is
actually got an electric floor
Wow this guy's a got fancy security
right opera man yeah I got that money
but look who's that hot vision guys
let's bail went on safe yeah it's like
you did that running around on purpose
we want to keep doors closed by the way
because the guards will notice that door
was supposed to be closed this is a new
one the punch cards were already selling
fast so it's not like he has more than
one of those right it's just there might
be another way to get in there though
who knows that's also the beauty of
these games as well right do they notice
the electrical flora song
when you first did this did you have to
like go back and find that power cell to
take out or did you actually just happen
upon it like the same way
no I using my semblance so when you use
the your foresight and can see like the
line your chance got it okay so I was
able to track I overheard the guards
saying about the electric floors okay
don't go in that room
and then I what's up Oh guys Oh booze
all right here we go play the audio the
new one we got yep
all right safe be number to the club
wherever one wants to kill me front door
which one's worse or easier try the club
maybe you can just book it out of it
like you did last time any more guards I
got two guards yeah don't forget guys
we're putting just honoured death of the
outsider stand-alone experience it's out
today $29.99
I think it's on all the next gen or
current gen consoles yep and PC
of course and as a reminder we're live
every day at 11 a.m. so you guys should
come by and hang out with us subscribed
ready to do that too so you get notified
when we go live and also when we make
cool features like history ups mm-hmm
what John that's working on this week
history of two DS Metroid that should be
up this weekend so if you're in a
Metroid at all you should check that out
also metro samus metroid san mr. turns
on the 3ds is about to come out and
that's not today supposed to be like I'm
sorry and that's supposed to be pretty
good stuff mm-hm go check out Peters
review yep but we're gonna try it wait
did you already get out I'm in the
spectra called now so we have tokens so
we are trying to attempt to get out to
safety so we can get kind of wrap this
stream up but until we get out okay team
is I the way to go take one of these do
shouldn't have been sipping on that
blood
this poor old SAP dead asleep about to
lose his face how's everyone doing my
blood transfusion was great went to
another plane some would say nice work
it's a dog softer you think all right
easy peasy I really like that ability
that's pretty cool and it has like
multiple applications we could also kill
people with it the bomb is still out to
lunch
try that I'll think are you trying to go
around
yes hi
all right so pretty much almost back to
where we started right all right okay
now what happens and we're done sick
okay so that was just kind of like a
taste of death of the outsider
standalone as mentioned earlier $29.99
on PC Steam ps4 Xbox one hmm
you're liking it so [ __ ] a lot I
think it's really good so if you guys
are into Dishonored you probably already
have it or if you're thinking about it
hopefully that maybe suede your decision
on perhaps buying it but you know a lot
of stuff's coming out like next one's
gonna be a crazy month we got
Wolfenstein to Mario Odyssey and
Assassin's Creed origins all in like one
day so you know a pretty good priced
game here and thank you John Luke we're
playing of course Scott you did some
cool stuff there we did some crazy
Theory crafting stuff I guess in a way
not really but it's fun so really
appreciate all you guys being with us
come back next Monday we'll see you then
and until next time have fun and have a
good weekend